In humans lactase persistent is characterized by the continued expression
of lactase into adulthood, there are two sequence positions in
humans that correlate with lactase persistence phenotypes, we have letters
at position minus 13910 based pairs in front of the
transcription
start site. And we have another position a
minus 22,018 base pairs or a letters in front
of the transcription start site. Now a G and
a C at this positions will result in low
or completely non lactase persistence so, as you
get older, you don't keep expressing lactase where as
an A and a T, this position do correlate
with lactase persistence into adulthood. Therefore, which position combination,
the top combination the G and the C of these positions or the A and the T at the
bottom positions, would you most likely expect to be
associated with lactose intolerance? Remember, you need to think about
what the trait of lactase persistence is. How it
relates to lactose intolerance. And which of these scenarios, right?
Which of these letter combinations. Is going to give you
or be associated with lactose intolerance. Go ahead and select
one of them now.